a new legislative process launched by
Parliament civil liberties committee
aims to further the return of irregular
migrants those with an unsuccessful
asylum claim plus all others illegally
residing in the EU by creating a
European travel document recognized by
fed country's figure suggests only 40%
of decisions to return refugees are
enforced annually it goes without saying
that this is detrimental to the
credibility and legitimacy of the
European Asylum and migration policies
in the eyes of all citizens it also
encourages the abuse of the asylum
system and the plans travel documents
would contain a standardized photo and
will be translated into the relevant EU
and third country of origin languages
one thing has to be made clear we send
back only those people who are not
entitled to international protection so
we are not sending refugees back we are
sending back people who are using the
asylum system and who are not in the
need of protection any piece vote on the
draft report this week with the hope
that an EU travel document could provide
some respite to an overly bureaucratic
Asylum system that has been so
inefficient to date